[Music]
morning all
the multi-million pound online fashion
retailer boohoo
is facing the possibility of a u.s
imports ban alongside
many of its suppliers following
widespread allegations over the use
of slave labor u.s customs and border
protection is considering allegations
from a british lawyer
who claims the boohoo is simply not
doing enough to stop
forced labour in the leicester factories
which make
many of its clothes boohoo for their
part say they've been working closely
with uk enforcement bodies
and that investigators examining
suppliers in leicester have found no
evidence
of modern day slavery martin brunt has
this exclusive report
from leicester
[Music]
boohoo sells itself and its fashions to
customers who are young
trendy and glamorous in contrast
many of its clothes are made in
leicester on a shabby industrial estate
mired in allegations of factory
sweatshops and slave labor
much of boohoo's advertising has a
backdrop of america
where its sales are worth 263 million
pounds
but that market is under threat
in its global war on slave labor the
united states already bans the imports
of many products
from zimbabwe and diamonds to certain
japanese video games
now it's being urged to target boohoo
and its suppliers
british campaigner duncan jepson has
petitioned u.s
customs and border protection for a ban
on products from boohoo
and most of leicester's garment industry
the evidence of boohoo and forced labor
is quite compelling i think this will be
a wake-up call
for british institutions about how
they're handling modern slavery and
forced labor
particularly in the communities like
leicester and leicester east
what obviously we'd all like is for
boohoo to
really get to grips with the governance
of their supply chain
to ensure that there is no wage theft to
ensure that
people have proper contracts in his
petition to u.s customs mr jepson writes
the dire extent of labor violations in
the apparel industry in leicester has
been common knowledge for a long time
and boohoo according to its own report
did not
and it is argued has yet to govern and
manage its supply chains effectively
enough
to eliminate the reasonable suspicion of
forced labor
if they do identify this in the supply
chain
in leicestershire the the potential
sanctions
to not trade in the united states are
enormous
but what it will do as well is it will
create a gap
for good businesses to come in and pay
people properly
last summer in a review boohoo's own
investigators
damned the company for ignoring
deplorable conditions within its supply
chain
boohoo has 14 million online customers
last year its profit soared to 92
million pounds
a month ago it bought the online
business of high street retailers
burton dorothy perkins and wallace forty
percent of boohoo's clothes are made in
leicester's factories
syed khilji took me inside his own
factory
he says a u.s ban would hurt but insists
working conditions have improved if
american government
taking any action and if they have
enough evidence to do that
then yes there will be a effect but i'm
sure
now on there won't be a problem in
leicester
i'm 100 confident on that in a statement
boohoo said
we have been working closely with uk
enforcement bodies
and it is important to note that
auditors and investigators
who are forensically examining suppliers
in leicester
have found no evidence of modern day
slavery
we are confident in the actions that we
are taking
to ensure that all of our products meet
and exceed
the cbp criteria on preventing the
product of forced labor
entering the u.s or any of our markets
the group continues to make excellent
progress as it works to implement the
reviews recommendations
and improve our supply chain in
leicester
accustomed investigation into boohoo and
the city's textile industry
is likely to take several months martin
brunt
sky news leicester
i'm very pleased to say that we're
joined now uh by the business secretary
quasi quoting
nice great to have you on the program
this morning um
obviously i i wonder if we can start
with
not necessarily anything specific to
boohoo um but some of the issues
that were raised in martin's report
there that as things stand
germany and another a number of other
european countries are
are passing laws that would make
companies liable for
for human rights breaches in the supply
chains
unless they had carried out their due
diligence now the modern slavery acts in
the uk
all companies have to do is is publish
an annual statement and
estimates vary but perhaps as many as
two and five
aren't doing so i'm just wondering is
the government minded to perhaps follow
in the footsteps of some of our european
colleagues and and give the modern
modern day slavery act some some more
kind of teeth and all of this
i think that uh we were very much on the
front foot
on this a few years ago clearly your
report was very
uh concerning i think incidents of
modern slavery are totally abhorrent
unacceptable um and i'd like to see more
details i think the modern slave reactor
we have is effective
uh many companies uh have said that to
me many business owners
uh but we'll have to look at information
and see what legislative response if any
is required
um well just to reiterate from from
boohoo they have said the following
we've been working closely with uk
enforcement bodies and it is important
to note that auditors and investigators
who are forensically examining suppliers
in leicester have found no evidence of
modern day slavery we see of course what
the response
is though however from from the u.s
government but let's let's do something
we rarely do
on this programme minister and at five
past seven in the morning
talk about football uh for a change
we're hearing from the prime minister
uh that in addition to the semi-finals
and the finals of the euro this summer
he might be happy to host the entire
thing look is it
as a statement of where we might be by
the summer in terms of a return to
normality this is a pretty big one
well i'm not sure what the actual
details of this competition might be but
clearly the prime minister set out last
week
a strong roadmap uh many people i've
spoken to have been
very relieved of the fact that there is
a timeline i think it set clear dates
uh by which uh we want to reopen things
and obviously we want to get things
started the economy
up and running as quickly as possible
but as the business sector i'm sure two
things one you'd probably be happy for
football to come home any day of the
week
but if there's a possibility of england
hosting the world cup in 2030 that's
something you're going to be
at full square behind absolutely i mean
i remember
uh you know i'm old enough to remember
the european uh cup uh
96 i think it was uh and that was a
great case
we'd be very very happy to see a
significant football tournament coming
back
uh to britain but can we just
specifically though about this summer
you know we're
we're hearing rumors that perhaps
wembley could be properly rolled out
that
given where we are with testing given
where we are with vaccination
we could have 90 000 people in wembley
you know perhaps one of the one or two
of us
it could also be they're cheating on
whoever's lucky enough to get to the
final i mean
are we anticipating people being able to
travel
here uh look it's not it's march the 2nd
uh now i don't want to run ahead of
ourselves i think there's still a
serious
issue that we have with coronavirus
there are still people who are
uh very ill the vaccine rollout has been
very successful we're very happy about
that
but i don't want to get too uh far ahead
of ourselves
and speculate about wembley in two or
three months time
okay but just in terms of of perhaps you
know
the biggest news to emerge from uh the
new downing street news conference
yesterday the evidence
that frankly all of us were waiting to
hear that reduction in mortality and
hospitalizations
amongst those that have been most
vaccinated so far
given the fact that there is no
indication
that as we move through the groups
vaccine efficacy
will in any way drop we're expecting it
in fact to get better the younger
people get this is the beginning of the
end isn't it
finally we can actually say this is the
light at the end of the tunnel
i agree i think uh the the information
is very encouraging
and the vaccine rollout has been very
successful i don't want to
over egg the pudding though i don't want
to say that we're
completely free of coronavirus i think
there are still
um dangers ahead but you're right the
numbers are encouraging
but i don't think it would be right for
me to to speculate about
football tournaments in three months
time indeed i'm just in terms of
of where we are in in combat in covet 19
in the united kingdom can you provide us
any update
as to whether or not we have we have
sourced that that sixth case
of the brazilian variant and indeed you
know have we had any indication from
surge testing in south gloucestershire
just yet
about any community transmission i think
we're still uh monitoring uh the
situation very closely
uh and you're quite right i think there
was one case uh of the brazilian foreign
as far as i know there are six cases but
there's one where uh the person
uh involved didn't uh fill in the forms
correctly
and we're still trying to uh work out
exactly uh what's happened
uh to that uh potential carrier but
we're we're dealing with this situation
and i'd like to remind you also that we
had the south african
uh variant and we've been dealing with
that too but the vaccine rollout has
been extremely successful and as you
said earlier
uh it does give us a lot of calls uh for
some hope
um just in terms of of what we're going
to be hearing this week of course
tomorrow
budget day and as is common on this
program i'm sure you will not be drawn
into commenting on specific measures
which will be announced then i do think
though from a philosophical and
ideological standpoint i mean william
hague has said
look you know we have to be clear with
the public we have to level with the
public some business
some personal taxes will have to rise
now
away from the budget it certainly seems
like at some point
over the remainder of this parliament
that tax rises
in some form have to be a part
of the economic response to covert 19. i
think the main thing
uh certainly on my desk and certainly
the chances as well
it's a support business through this
very difficult time and you will know
that the
support that the prime the prime
minister and the chancellor in
particular have given to the economy is
unprecedented we've given something like
put in something like 285 billion pounds
uh since the corona uh virus pandemic
crisis began and i think uh in
tomorrow's budget the chancellor will be
very
minded uh to support uh struggling
businesses
uh struggling uh people as well and so
that we can get through this very
difficult pandemic
as you say there have been huge amounts
of money
spent uh since the beginning of this
pandemic in terms of business support in
terms of support for individuals and
and so on however yesterday we learned
that the government in in you know the
government in terms of its
foreign aid budget is not just halfing
is cutting by by 54
the amount of money we give to yemen why
are we choosing this moment to do so
i don't think that um i haven't seen the
numbers but the actual amount
that we're reducing is something like
0.7
of gdp to 0.5 percent
and i think it was felt that uh given
the incredible stress
uh that we've gone through uh in britain
um
giving 0.7 of the of the economy uh
in this particular year was was
challenging i think the amount
has been reduced by little and after all
the european average is only
is 0.45 so we're still giving more of
our national wealth
than i understand that eu country so i
try to answer your question but i think
that
um i i think that this is a temporary
measure i think the chancellor has said
that we want to
fulfill our commitments and we are doing
so
yeah it's a temporary measure at a time
when tens of millions of people
uh in yemen are at threat of death from
uh from from famine we gave 214 million
pounds
to yemen last year indeed beginning of
december we announced an additional 11
million pounds at the foreign secretary
telling the un security council
you know new uk aid will save lives by
making sure the poorest yemenis can feed
their families
the uk cannot solve this crisis alone
other donors must now release their
funding
and contribute more support to prevent
this becoming an even bigger
tragedy that's the foreign secretary to
the security council calling on the
world to give more money
and then we announce that we're going to
cut it in half i think you would do that
anyway and i think
uh when you look at yemen and i've
traveled in the gulf a lot there's a lot
more that
countries in the gulf uh saudi arabia
and other countries
um can do to support
uh humanitarian crises uh in that region
before we cut our own aid budget i mean
we're talking about
we're talking about lives here i know
the only thing i'm going to suggest is
you know the u.n secretary general and
others
are warning of a pending crisis in yemen
and we've just count the amount of money
that we're giving them by half
i think britain has always been uh at
the forefront of international aid
responses i think the people in this
country extremely generous
uh the government has uh provided all
sorts of financial support
uh and also diplomatic support to crises
in the region
and will continue to do so as it's often
the case minister when when we speak
at this time in the morning there is a
union flag over
your shoulder as there has been with
many colleagues clearly the union
has been more into the spotlight of in
recent times than perhaps it has been
for for a long time in terms of
at the conservative party at least since
the the last independence referendum
i just wonder if you agree with the
prime minister when he says that another
scottish
referendum is irrelevant uncalled for
and unnecessary i've always thought that
the
issue of scottish independence is
something for the people
in scotland i do remember in 2014 i
think it was that they said that the
referendum would settle
the issue for 25 years for a generation
and i am surprised at how often
uh it's come back but it's up to the
scottish people to decide
uh when and whether they want to
referendum
do the struggles between alex salmond
and nicolas sturgeon perhaps make it
rather easier
for the government to resist calls for a
second independence referendum
particularly if as
as everyone expects the snp uh do rather
well
come the scottish parliamentary
elections in may well
i don't know how well uh any of these
parties are going to do clearly
there's been a lot of noise about what's
going on in the smp i think that's a
matter for them their internal
process their discipline i'm not going
to be drawn in on on the internal
politics
of the snp let's just see what happens
uh in the hollywood election in may
quasi-quarantine great to have you on
the show this morning thanks being with
us
thank you our political correspondent
tom rayner as always lurking in the
wings um tom we'll let out to you
i thought it was the note of caution
that the business secretary wanted
uh to convey you were giving him every
opportunity that there was
to embrace uh the suggestion that the
european championships could be held
entirely all games in the uk which the
prime minister mooted
in a newspaper interview and it was
notable that quasi quantum said he
didn't want to get ahead of himself
that it's march the second the dangers
lie ahead that rather begs the question
why talk about it in the terms that the
prime minister has in his interview with
harry call of the sun
well it does but we've seen this before
haven't we in fact boris johnson has
been
i would say in the last month or so uh
at payne's
to try and suppress some of the
boosterism which is characteristic
of his approach to politics generally uh
that has been kept in check
clearly uh in the newspaper interview
when it comes to football
it is being held up as something which
is actually about more than just
football it's about a
symbol of what lies ahead after
uh restrictions are lifted but i think
you know quasi-cuatang they're saying
very clearly that while the vaccine
program is being successful
and while all of the data that we were
receiving yesterday at the downing
street press conference
is very encouraging there are still
dangers ahead he doesn't want to over
egg the pudding
as he put it and he didn't want to
speculate about a football tournament in
three months time
and i think that that is notable because
clearly
you know he's thinking about what is
going to be in the budget tomorrow he's
thinking about the economic picture from
his brief
we've had lots of spoonfuls of sugar in
terms of announcements from the treasury
over the last few days we don't yet know
what
medicine rishi sunak is about to
administer and i think you know
the tone of the business secretary then
uh potentially quite revealing about the
fact that in government at least
there's caution and perhaps a wariness
that
even though it feels like we might be
getting towards the light at the end of
the tunnel that there's
some way to go yeah all i'm going to do
is spend the rest of the morning
thinking about euro 96 for goodness
sakes tom thanks very much
still to come on the program this
morning at 25 to 8 we'll be asking
whether the pm
is undermining the uk's climate goals
with a new coal mine planned for cumbria
[Music]
at quarter to eight tackling knife crime
we'll find out how an
interactive video game is helping
educate young people in scotland
about the dangers of carrying a knife
and at 20 past eight we'll hear how the
nation's renewed
love of parks is leading to concerns
about the damage caused by
record numbers of visitors
but let's discuss the breaking news from
nigeria in the past hour and a half or
so
gunmen have released 279 schoolgirls who
were kidnapped from a boarding school
in the northwest of the country let's
speak now
to our africa correspondent john sparks
to try and fill in a few of the details
morning john
this is of course a good news story
first and foremost but just explain
exactly
what on earth led to the kidnapping of
almost
300 schoolgirls
yeah good morning neil very distressing
story
279 girls from a town called
jangebe in zamfara state that is in
the northwest of nigeria released
overnight and then assembled in the
morning in a government building
for the nation's media to capture the
images i mean it must have been a very
very distressing experience for the
girls and also
for their parents as well what we know
is that
a group of kidnappers almost certainly a
criminal gang
took the girls on friday night there
were about a hundred of these guys
dressed up in military uniforms
carrying automatic weapons they went
into the town
challenged the the men to uh some sort
of fight or a battle we understand
didn't get one and then headed over to
the student hostel and took
the girls and we believe that around 50
of the girls managed to escape at the
time by hiding under beds and
and hiding in the toilets that sort of
thing government officials said the
girls were
were taken away they said they knew
exactly who had done it they knew
where the girls had been taken but they
didn't want to mount a rescue operation
because they didn't want there to be any
casualties any
potential deaths so very difficult
situation for them but it does beg the
question how
released was money paid and there
certainly will be a strong suspicion
that
either money was paid or that vehicles
were handed over
because i have to say this is this is
becoming a growth
industry in uh nigeria it's happening
increasingly
frequently criminal gangs bandits taking
advantage of the precarious
security situation in the north and
central areas of that country
john many thanks indeed
police in myanmar have once again
clashed with protesters
firing tear gas to disperse crowds in
the city of yangon
it comes as foreign ministers from
neighboring countries we're due to whole
talks with the military in an
effort to end the deadly violence
hope from that let's ask our southeast
asia correspondent siobhan robbins well
we'll just on that point
we were talking yesterday about the
weekends violence the seeming escalation
i'm not detecting from where i am any
any sign that this is calming down
no and i don't think it will calm down
now what we've seen for the last month
is uh the military being frustrated by
the level of pushback that they've got
from people on the streets and we've
seen that both in these protests but
also in the civil disobedience movement
which has been going on behind the
scenes
it's something we don't talk about a lot
but it is actually a key
protest strategy what they've been doing
is things like bank workers haven't been
going into banks railway workers have
been walking out they're bringing
down the way society can function
because essentially they say for example
if you work in a bank if the
military leaders can't get hold of money
then the country will grind to a halt
and that's really frustrating it's
beginning to frustrate
those who've taken over the country in
this
coup and then so what we're seeing is
this uptick in violence because they've
told people
initially that they've done this for the
good of the country it's clear that
thousands tens of thousands of
protesters don't agree with them
they then told protesters you know to go
home they tried to restrict them with
restricting the internet restricting the
phones that hasn't worked
so they've now started using increasing
violence and i think the problem is
is this is going to be a pattern which
continues and how long it continues
is the concern because we know that the
government or the military leaders
have set themselves the target of
setting a new election but we don't
actually know when that's going to be
they've said in the next
year but really is that going to happen
let's remember the military held on to
power
in the past for around 50 years so i
think the real concern is again we're
seeing clashes in yangon
in uh calais as well more people being
injured and how long will this go on for
siobhan many thanks indeed uh let's take
you through a few of the other
uh main stories of the day now shall we
uh prince philip
well he spent the night at some
bartholomew's hospital in london
after 13 nights at the private king
edward the seventh hospital
in a statement buckingham palace
confirmed that the duke is responding to
treatment
and is expected to remain in hospital
until at least the end of the week
the scottish government has agreed to
release legal advice from its
court battle with alex salmond this
morning after msps threatened a vote of
no confidence it comes after opposition
parties
indicated they'd back a motion in the
deputy first minister
john swinney if he refused to release
the documents
apple in a statement last night john
swinney said this we have to acknowledge
that the
issues at stake now are not normal the
very integrity of the legal system is
being questioned
serious allegations have been made this
material allows people
to confirm that these allegations are
false
the man who was walking lady gaga's
three dogs when he was shot by
thieves said he had a very close call
with death
writing on instagram ryan fisher thanked
the healthcare workers who saved his
life
as well as the canine he laid next to
him after the attack
who he described as an angel
the only picture painted by winston
churchill during the second world war
has
sold at auction for more than eight
million pounds
the moroccan landscape which had been
owned by the actor angelina jolie
beat the previous record for a painting
by churchill by
6 million pounds
there are calls for the government to do
more to reduce fat content in food
health experts say it could prevent tens
of thousands of deaths
and reduce obesity levels by millions as
guys becky cottrell reports
while the world has been in the grip of
a pandemic the uk
continues to battle an epidemic the
foods we know we shouldn't love
slowly poisoning us thanks in part to
one of our longtime dietary foes
fat obesity is a huge problem in the uk
as everyone knows two-thirds of the
population now overweight
and a huge number of beasts a new paper
by the wolfson institute at queen mary
university of london
has a proposal to wean us off the
saturates that have saturated
supermarket shelves and takeaway menus
it says that reducing fats in processed
foods by 20
could lead to 4.5 million fewer people
becoming overweight or obese over 20
years the changes could prevent
97 000 deaths from coronary heart
disease
and stroke as well as 183 000 cases
of type 2 diabetes so how do you cure a
national addiction
to fat we're suggesting vegetable
residues which are healthy and contain
fiber and a good food you immediately
reduce the calorie content
of that food without affecting the
serving size
obesity gives covert 19 a much better
chance at making you seriously ill
the prime minister lost weight after his
own battle with a virus saw him
hospitalized
now many want him to do more to help the
country slim down
any any kind of tax incentive is always
going to be welcomed by businesses
anyway
and so it makes sense in the field of
obesity to um
give handouts in the same way has been
has been done in other areas such as
electric cars
for instance reducing our fat intake
under this new proposal would be gradual
but the state of the population's health
needs immediate attention
obesity one of many vulnerabilities the
virus feeds off
becky cottrell sky news
time to see how the weather is looking
this morning nas is standing by at the
wall with the details morning as
uh it was very chilly this morning yep
it is a cold murky morning across many
areas basically like yesterday morning
and today we are going to see some
bright spells but some places staying
murky and cold
all day
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so today's weather is much
like it was yesterday starting off
rather gray cloudy
cold some patches of frost across the
north and west
but then it will be brightening up with
mild conditions for most places but not
everywhere some central eastern parts
will be rather cloudy murky and cold all
day
so at the moment the patches of mist and
fog are fairly extensive
especially across central southern and
eastern parts of england and eastern
parts of
scotland too and most of it will lift
and clear into this afternoon
so we will see some sunshine developing
after a murky morning
and a bit of a frosty one across parts
of ireland northern ireland as well as
the majority of scotland north west
england
most of wales and southern counties of
england and even parts of east anglia as
well
will become brighter too but across the
far east of wales into the midlands
perhaps some central parts of england up
towards lincolnshire
yorkshire eastern parts of scotland it's
going to be
rather cloudy once again with rather
murky conditions and it will be cold
across these areas temperatures
struggling to get above around
five or six degrees celsius up into
double figures pretty much everywhere
else
in the sunshine the light winds feeling
mild
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
nurse thanks very much indeed coming up
after the break here on breakfast
my critics are calling boris johnson's
backing of a cumbria coal mine
hypocritical
[Music]
welcome back the business secretary
quasiquating has told us it is
too early to speculate about hosting
more football matches
at the summer's european championships
after boris johnson told the sun
newspaper the uk
would be able to host more games if so
asked by
uefa all this as the chancellor has set
aside nearly three million pounds to
launch a bid
for the 2030 world cup i asked mr
quarten
what he thought about the possibility of
holding the tournament
i remember uh you know i'm old enough to
remember the european uh
cup 96 i think it was uh and that was a
great
case we'd be very very happy to see uh a
significant football tournament coming
back
uh to britain but can we just
specifically though about this summer
you know we're
we're we're hearing rumors that perhaps
wembley could be
properly rolled out that given where we
are with testing given where we are with
vaccination
we could have 90 000 people in wembley
you know perhaps one of the one or two
of us it could also be they're cheating
on whoever's lucky enough to get to the
final i mean
are we anticipating people being able to
travel here
uh it's not it's march the 2nd uh
now i don't want to run ahead of
ourselves i think there's still a
serious
issue that we have with coronavirus
there are still people who are
uh very ill the vaccine rollout has been
very successful we're very happy about
that
but i don't want to get uh too far ahead
of ourselves
and speculate about wembley in two or
three months time
[Applause]
joining us now on the programme the
shadow home secretary nick thomas
simmons very good morning to you
um and of course i'm sure you'll have
your own memories of euro 96 which we
can perhaps talk about
at another point but in terms of what
we're hearing from
from the government this morning the
data on vaccine efficacy that came from
the downing street
news conference yesterday is something
that i'm sure you cheered as much
as anyone else it it does feel like we
are moving into the
the end game of our battle against
covid19
would you like to see the uk hosting or
england hosting more
uh of the euros this summer
well uh good morning annie it's good to
join you with regard
to euro 96 yes of course i've got great
memories growing up of euro 96 i'm also
a big football fan who wouldn't want to
see a football tournament being hosted
here in the united kingdom
again of course but the focus at the
moment
has to be on ensuring that we continue
with the successful vaccine rollout and
we have in place
measures to protect it now one of the
four tests
that the prime minister has set for
moving through the
different steps is of course about covid
variants
and i've been arguing i've argued on
your show previously
that we should have in place a
comprehensive system of hotel testing at
the border
to do everything we practically can to
prevent
variants from coming overseas that
threaten the efficacy of our vaccine so
yes of course be wonderful to host the
football tournament in the future
but the focus has to be on a vaccine
rollout now and protecting it
um so in your call for for everyone who
arrives here in the united kingdom to be
subjected to hotel quarantine
how long do you think that we would need
to keep that sort of scheme in place for
that
well firstly there would always be
exceptions there's a list of exceptions
to quarantine now and of course hauliers
would be
exempt but it does need to be a
comprehensive system
you have to take of course scientific
and expert advice as to precisely how
long
that would remain in place but clearly
you
have to reach an advanced stage of the
vaccine
rollout protect the vaccine roll out
secondly you have to allow our superb
scientists
to continue mapping the different
genomic sequences the different
mutations
to learn as much as they possibly can
about the virus
so you have to have it in place for that
duration but there is an
urgency to this we have seen the
brazilian strain reaching our shores
on the 10th of february five days before
the government introduced even the
limited measure of hotel quarantining
that we do have on the 15th
so we know that government slowness at
our border has been a huge problem
throughout the pandemic
the government needs to act i i wonder
what we have if we can talk about the
situation
um as regards the labour party in
liverpool and the elections
uh for the mayoralty there cursed armors
big pitch ever since he became
party leader was his competence that
labour
has put the jeremy corbyn days behind it
but in the liverpool mayoral race labour
has pulled
all three candidates all three labour
candidates a day before ballots were
supposed to go out to party members
they're all counsellors they're all
labour councillors what is the issue
with them
i i'm not i haven't been a part of that
uh
process so i don't know the particular
uh
issue with uh the the candidates that
you've mentioned what i do know is that
there is now uh a process
in place basically a candidate
will be selected and i think what's
important
is that we now get behind whoever that
candidate is
uh going forward and make sure that we
retain the mayoralty for labor
yeah that's that well that's the problem
isn't it that labour that liverpool is a
big labor city
and we have a situation where on the
ground the labour party is in complete
disarray without yet
a mayoral candidate having been selected
i understand you're not afraid with the
details
but you've got to be pretty grumpy about
the way it's been handled
look i always look forward in these
things not back as i say i haven't been
a part of this process and i'm not
okay with the details of it i'm not a
member of the national
executive committee nor am i uh you know
part of this uh process in any way but
uh what i see is now a determination to
get a candidate in place and to get out
there campaigning
we know that you know liverpool has been
hugely affected like
so many other parts of the country by
the tory policies of the last 11 years
we need those strong
labor voices in liverpool to stand up
for the city
we need to get our candidate in place
and get on with campaigning
for them to be elected nick thomas
simmons good to have you on the show
thanks for being with us
boris johnson has been warned by a group
of foreign ambassadors
the backing plans for a new coal mine in
cumbria
puts them at risk of looking like a
hypocrite
uh let's try and explain exactly what is
going on here we're joined now
by the co-founder of the environmental
think tank e3g
and the former government advisor of
course at tom burke tom great to have
you on the show
this morning um can we just explain can
you just explain
exactly what is going on here we
understand the uk's leadership role
in cop fast approaching of course but
we're opening a coal mine
what on earth is happening here
i wish i wish i knew um clearly
you have a situation in which the prime
minister is asking people as he is
at the summit that uh britain is hosting
today
of the powering past coal alliance
they're asking people to do more
to drive coal out of our economy at the
same time
as he's opening a coal mine himself now
i should think
to most uh of his peers that's very
baffling
and it certainly doesn't encourage them
to
treat him as a serious partner uh when
it comes to the big meeting in glasgow
at the end of the year
none of which of course tom is to say
that the uk hasn't made incredible
strides
over the past few years in cutting
reliance on
carbon within the national grid
no you're absolutely right and that's
what makes this this mistake
uh in a way so bad because we have
really
managed both to drive down our own
emissions
while making our economy grow at the
same time so we've proved
that that could be done and also in
things like the climate change act and
indeed
like the powering past coal alliance
given the world a real lead
and yet to sort of mess it up for some
sort of
uh clearly lack of grip
inside the government is is a really bad
error and
it's an error with consequences because
all of
the leaders that he has to get to agree
at the cop in glasgow they've all got
difficult problems at home with their
own net transition
and this kind of mistake encourages
their
internal opposition of his peers and
that of course is not welcome
i i suppose though those those who argue
explicitly
in favor of the coke mine in in cumbria
point out that it's
producing special coking material for
use within the steel industry
boosts the uk boost the uk end of that
particular industry
reduces our reliance on importing the
same material from
from overseas reduces our carbon
footprint in that regard
there's a case that you might be able to
make for it but the
in a sense the substantive case uh about
that this might have a marginal benefit
for
uh carbon emissions is outweighed by the
real political damage that's done
you could very easily have uh got the
timing of this right so it didn't get in
the way
uh you know there's no uh a sense in
which
a decision literally as small as this
one should be having consequences
for a conference as big as the one we're
going to have in glasgow at the end of
the year
so again it just reinforces that idea
that there's a bit of a lack of grip
in the prime minister's office and
that's something that makes
other leaders feel that he may not be a
reliable partner
just finally tom just briefly in terms
of our nation's
energy security we understand in the
past the reliance that there's been on
you know natural gas and so on coming
from the east we know how
temperamental those pipelines can
sometimes be don't we
to an extent need to retain some uh or
some capacity to use carbon within the
national grid
to guard against those prospects i don't
think we need to retain
uh carbon uh burning carbon for our
power system i think there may be an
argument
for some aspects of industry about what
they call the hard to abate
uh uh industries where we might need to
find some way
of using carbon uh burning carbon
in a carbon neutral way in a net zero
way but i don't think there's any need
at all for it
in our our system and again if you
really want to
ensure your energy security then driving
bills down by improving the energy
efficiency of our
notoriously poorly insulated homes
is the best way possible and again the
government's just made a real mess
of a very good idea of putting a lot of
money
into people's insulating people's homes
and it just
messed it up in the way it went about it
so it's not
it's not a problem of our energy
security as much as our national
competence
indeed tom burke great to see you this
morning thanks for joining us on the
show
still to come on breakfast this morning
at tackling
knife crime we'll be finding out how an
interactive video game is helping
educate young people in scotland
about the dangers of carrying knives
now a new video game aimed at reducing
knife crime is to be launched in
scotland
the game aims to teach young people to
speak up and get help
if a friend or someone they know is
carrying
a knife uh well let's speak now uh to
oriole taylor
uh from the group no knives better lives
to give us a bit more information on
this all right great to have you on the
show this morning and
before we talk about the game just just
tell us a little bit about how much of
an
issue knife crime amongst young people
remains
in scotland over the past few years of
course we've heard a huge amount
about the very significant work that the
violence reduction unit
had in reducing knife crime in glasgow
for example
and yeah so the numbers in scotland have
decreased a lot and particularly over
the last 10 years they have come down
and but you know we work in a prevention
context
we alongside the valence structure unit
and other national partners
it's um prevention we work with and
prevention doesn't
just happen in a crisis context so
we continue to work with young people um
all the time to educate them and to
support them and give them the
information they need around knife crime
um it is coming down in scotland it is
not common for young people to be
carrying knives in scotland
but one instant of carrying and using a
knife can be one too many and it's quite
a devastating effect in the whole
community
so it's still work that needs to be done
and it is ongoing
yeah well tell us then a little bit
about the game nay danger love the title
um it's kind of one of those choose your
own adventure games which back in my day
we used to do with a book you're now
using computers it's amazing the way
technology has got advanced over the
years
yeah it's a really exciting new game we
were actually approached by
the company pocket size hands who
developed the game and they were using
us to consult on another bit of work
they were doing
and then we just kind of thought well
this would be a really exciting new
thing to bring to scotland
and to the young people across scotland
we've done plays in the past we do lots
of other projects like peer education
and we've done foreign theater in
schools and we thought this might be
something that's different
it's engaging young people where they
like to hang out where
you know they're online they're doing
gaming so why not look at how we can
bring our messaging
into a game i guess it was hard for us
to vision initially how that could look
but pocket size hands were brilliant at
helping us bring that together so
we can get all the serious messaging and
open up the dialogue with young people
but also
make it really fun and engaging which
was really important and we also worked
with the group um
youth just us which was a group of care
and justice experienced young people
and they helped us go through the script
um
taking ideas opinions experiences and
helping that build all that into the
game which was fantastic
and actually four of them ended up being
the voices for the characters in the
game we were really
happy with as well so that really helped
us shape the game to make sure it was
um authentic for young people and it was
still really fun and engaging to do as
well
yeah i mean you mentioned the word there
that i was about i was about to deploy
authenticity
when you're speaking to young people is
is absolutely key isn't it i mean if you
you start talking about being with it or
hip you know they tend to turn their
noses up and exit the room you want to
speak to them in their own language
yeah so no noise better lives and we
take a youth work approach so we really
you know we're part of newslink scotland
which is the national youth agency for
youth workers
and it's we take that youth work
approach which is including young people
and including their voices
and everything that we do so we try and
make sure that we instead of just
coming in and talking at them that we
engage with young people
and we we make it as engaging as
possible so the game is there to be
played it's interactive it plays you
play in groups you play it with a
facilitator so that would be a teacher
or a youth worker
and we've got this kind of a user manual
that goes along with it so there's
points in the game you can pause you can
have discussion you can open up that
dialogue with young people
and that's really the important part
with this game as well it's opening up
that conversations with young people
building on trusted relationships
allowing them to know that they can
explore and discuss that with you so
they can look at
all the aspects of the game and not you
know as well as playing it through and
being fun engaging so it's got those
elements to it as well so you can have
that discussion
um with that youth worker or that
teacher as well which i think is really
important to go alongside
that really is really is oriole taylor
national coordinator for no knives
better lives
great to have you on the show this
morning best of luck with the game thank
you
time for the weather here's nice
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning today is a repeat
performance of
yesterday's weather so starting off
rather murky this morning
most of the mist and fog lifting and
clearing into this afternoon revealing
sunny spells for most places but some
areas will stay cloudy and cold and
murky all day
so at the moment mr low cloud is fairly
extensive out there this morning
and there are some clear spells across
parts of the north and west where
there's a bit of a frost in places too
it's a cold morning of course
as well into this afternoon most of that
burns away so we are going to see some
good spells of sunshine developing but
as you can see across some parts of the
midlands towards uh
lincolnshire uh yorkshire eastern parts
of scotland and perhaps edging into
western parts of east anglia
it will be cloudy cold and murky today
[Music]